all right
tyler tyler uh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally uh
alabama what city coleman where is that
uh it's kind of right there in the
middle okay exactly yeah near birmingham
uh close to it yeah okay and uh tell me
about your family you grew up with both
your parents
no they were divorced how how would you
describe your childhood
uh it was all right uh the cameras
things started getting weird what kind
of stuff was going on
uh i don't know i i there was like a
joint custody thing i wasn't really sure
how that worked and
just strange things back and forth
between my parents and
uh my dad got really weird and strange
like really really peculiar and
he got cut straight custody of me after
my mother she started doing like these
drugs and stuff
i don't really understand any of that
back then were both your parents using
drugs
no i don't really know what my dad was
doing he was just really mysterious
yeah there's a strange thing going on
how would you describe your childhood
uh it was pleasant until uh it that [ __ ]
hit the fan when she had the fan it was
real [ __ ] and it went straight in my
face
what kind of like abuse or anything like
that yeah quite yeah quite a bit um
i mean i don't really i don't really
talk about it and i don't like to
remember it all and most of it is like
repressed or something so
yeah there'd be times when he i would
like i would wake up
in the night and he would be in my room
you know uh like standing over me and
and
and doing things and it's just like like
sexual yeah
really yeah and um and you're how old
i think the first time i realized it was
like eight or nine yeah
yeah and then yeah and then uh
things uh just progress he would get
aggressive
extremely aggressive and and between
that and
how i uh i had to leave um you know like
the whole
family and everything he uh uh
it just it messed me up yeah what kind
of kid were you in high school
i tried to be normal but i wasn't i just
i just didn't talk to anybody i
tried to save myself completely
yeah did you finish school yeah
you got out through high school what'd
you do after school i barely finished
school i um
i got back in contact with my mother and
my um my sisters
and my brother and uh
they weren't really in a good position
anyways and they you know
they didn't have anything you know to do
i really just got the hell away from my
dad yeah yeah
you know that was the only thing that
that i that i really wanted to do is
to get away from him because he was not
where'd you go what did you do with your
life after
after living your family uh
well well i didn't really know what to
do i didn't know how to actually provide
for myself
or do anything for myself at all you
know and so
i just i guess i was just just like
leeching off of my mother you know after
that because i didn't know what to do
how old are you now right now i'm 28.
you're 28. yeah
but that was about 18 and um
i just ended up being homeless for a
long time and
just how long you been homeless since
then oh is that right yeah
you don't look very homeless i don't no
you look you look like you could be
you know an upstanding member of society
i wish i could but i just it's not it's
not it's not punching for me
it doesn't function nothing functions
properly when i'm in public so
i don't like going in public i don't
like being around people at all
uh i just i don't like it it's just i
just
yeah i'm more of like a just stay myself
kind of person yeah
do you have any friends um
i think they're imaginary
but they're not i don't i'm sure they're
not
and looking back at your childhood would
you blame
the just the way you were raised as to
why you're like you are
i wouldn't blame i wouldn't blame it on
anything i would change anything i like
myself
yeah and it's great i'm just different
from everybody else
are drugs a part of your life uh
sometimes off and on
what do you use uh
[Applause]
i guess pretty much anything yeah yeah
what have you played with down here
uh actually i've been pretty clean for
about
three months now so really yeah yeah you
look fairly
clean um where are you staying now
you're on skid row
uh no no i'm i'm uh i have a uh this
like
little fort or tent built somewhere i
think it's near olympic
so you're a little on the edge of the
outskirts of skid row
and how how do you find living in la
homeless
it's pretty nice the weather's the
weather's tolerable right
uh no i like it it's it's it's nice
weather's good
it's reclusive and how do you support
yourself
um i i guess i don't i just live off of
whatever i find
you go to the shelters for food and
stuff like that no no
how do you feed yourself i usually just
eat out of the garbage
really
going through garbage through dumpsters
what kind of stuff have you found
oh lots of nice things really really
good things the people there are so much
so much the way that they shouldn't
throw away yes los angeles i think
yeah what kind of things are you uh
uh some pretty uh i guess they seem
valuable
i think they're valuable just clothes um
lots of clothes really nice clothes yeah
the homeless community down here is the
best dressed the food and things
crowd you ever and uh yeah i agree with
that
and um um
i guess pieces of furniture enough to
build almost a a whole
small little you know living yeah right
thing
have you ever been left um i've tried
quite a few times
yeah i i i can fall in love but
it's just it's been a hell of a time so
it's not really worth it anymore
what emotions do you deal with do you
get um
it's like a roller coaster if i if i
think or try to deal with it it's a
roller coaster but so usually i just you
know just coast on
like neutrality i guess yeah are you
lonely
uh quite often yeah
what's been the hardest point of your
life hmm
i'm not sure
is all of the above
what's been the best time of your life
the best time of my life
i guess when i'm just i get in this like
mindset uh
when i'm on drugs or if i'm not on drugs
or whatever and it's just it's like it's
just
a whole different me you know and i just
i i'll forget about everything
and just be a different person and even
if it's you know just me by myself in a
room alone or a house alone and i just
play dress up and you know
listen to music and just take pictures
and do weird things and like
do whatever and not feel bad about
anything
and not have any friends or contact with
anyone i just it's nice
you know it's a lot more do interesting
do you feel like your life has
has meaning is there anything that
you're doing that yeah quite a lot
quite a few things that i i find
meaningful
um i i uh i try to um
like do these uh like weird researches
into
um like uh maybe spiritual or not
spiritual but
the the cultures and things that people
have uh either forgotten or um
or haven't seen or or didn't know
existed
uh i think possibly that i am
you know doing something pretty good
with that i don't know what it's going
to come to
eventually but hopefully it'll it'll
blossom
yeah yeah it's interesting
have you have you ever quite a bit have
you
ever seen a doc you know anyone about
mental health issues or
yes yes i've been in prison and i've
been to jail a few times and i i i
they do psych evaluations and things
when they said that it was there was
possible like schizophrenic tendencies
but they said that
i was pretty uh you know clear-headed
and
concise with everything so they really
never diagnosed me with anything
yeah i'm not a doctor but you seem in
some ways very together and otherwise
you're emotional yeah you're interesting
thank you do you feel like your family
like let you down uh i did for a while
and uh
the the one thing that really changed my
whole
viewpoint of the world i guess is that i
spent 10 years
away from one half of my family and was
with my dad who was this really awful
person i didn't understand that you know
he had his own issues and i got over
that
eventually but um he would just talk
just terrible about
my mother and everything and then when
um
i first got you know made recontact with
her or
she the thing that just really just
struck me was
she was talking about him and we were
talking about him and we were trying to
catch up with each other and she almost
said something a bad bad about him and
she said
wait no i can't i'm not going to talk
bad about your father in front of you
because it's still your your your dad
and i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna say anything bad about him
because that wouldn't be right wow
you know
do you feel like life is unfair um
you can see you can see how you can see
any kind of viewpoint you want as long
as you know how to look at them yeah
i've heard it i've heard it all but i
just wonder from from your perspective
you know you it sounds like you haven't
had a whole lot of
wonderful times in your life you haven't
had a great childhood you haven't had
a lot of support no no no but i
i feel that um there's got to be a
reason for that and
i'm definitely tapped into something
quite a few times that definitely told
me for 100 certain that i'm
okay and all right and that no matter
what i'm doing
uh there's gonna be some sort of um you
know
uh reason for everything even if it does
seem a little unfair
do you take responsibility for the
situation you're in and
oh yeah it's my life yeah so yeah i mean
i i i it wouldn't be my life if i didn't
right
what are you afraid of uh um what do you
worry about
not existing
in what way i mean like like dying or
just just not dying i'm not afraid of
dying or after life it's just not being
relevant not being
uh it's more like the um the concept of
if you do die and there is nothing
are you religious yes you are
so are you are you questioning whether
god exists and all that no not at all
you know that question is there
it's like how do you know unless you you
take leap and i've i've been pretty you
know
yeah i'll take a leap of faith quite a
few times yeah uh
and continue where do you see yourself
in in like five years
oh i i don't think that's even uh
grappable
do you have any dreams any hopes you're
still young um
yeah quite a few it's it i pick a
category and
it just skyrockets you know just in
whatever i'm thinking about and
then um if i change my mind it kind of
does the same thing you have a hard time
applying yourself towards the goal
no i can apply myself to many goals
it's just sticking to which one i've
picked at that time is a little
different
so you you you jump from one plan to the
next
um yes yes uh i've always i i've
actually made progress because i
i do uh take time at some point in these
little intervals of my my
persons or whatever i've been or my
progression as a person
i will take time to go back and you know
check myself and see if
see if um i'm actually you know uh
you know in a cl you know clear state of
mind or
you know just you know do uh like
discipline on myself uh
uh progressive uh or see if i'm actually
making progress
or if i'm not making progress or if it's
like uh declining or not
and have you been on medications before
no
i wonder i wonder if that might might
help you
uh it's possible yeah it is quite
possible
and what's the most important lesson
you've learned in your life um
the most important lesson
um
just never be afraid to just speak and
be myself
no matter what uh what possible
outcome it is that's a good one that's
great yeah
all right tyler thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you for talking
with me and uh i wish you the best of
luck out there
ah thank you thank you
you're very interesting
you